Presentacion
Salvador que hombre mortal puede tocar la belleza de este libro de Hebreos sin arruinarla Senor.
Somos incapaces de tocar un libro tan sublime, tan precioso, con un mensaje directamente de tu corazon Senor.
Por eso Cristo te suplico que en estos días, que seas tu nuestro maestro, que tu nos partas el Pan de Vida.
Abre nuestros ojos y nuestros espíritus, para que podamos ver la gloria de tu rostro que resplandece a través de este mensaje de Hebreos.
Abre nuestros corazones a la revelación de tu belleza que hay aquí
Para que nunca mas caminemos de la misma manera Señor.
Oh planta en lo mas profundo de nuestro corazón las bellezas, las verdades, la gloria que hay aquí Señor.
Para que nunca sean olvidadas, Oh, arraiga en nuestro corazón estas verdades.
Oh Salvador que siempre en el valle de la sombra de la muerte tengamos la gracia para regresar a la belleza revelada aquí Señor.
Cristo Jesús estamos esperando en ti, esperando en ti, Oh maestro de Galilea enséñanos por favor.
Padre en el nombre de tu Hijo precioso, te lo pedimos, te lo rogamos, dándote gracias.
Por las migajas de tu mesa, gracias Señor,